all right When The War started
they protected me
for better care of me than humans sort
of
and our people Maya
it's just programming
ten years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
this is a fight for our very existence
we are this close to winning the war
a I are developing a super weapon
leave it
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
no you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven so we're the same we can't go to
heaven because you're not good
and I'm not a person
you're gonna do with the thing is
she looks like a little girl now but
she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
you said you want me
what do you want sweetie for robots to
be free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
[Music]